I don't have time to do anything I don't
I want to shower eat my dinner and go to
sleep I don't have time or energy to
cook by dinner either like I don't have
energy to work out like that's out the
window like I'm so upset oh my God
nothing to do with my job at all but
just like the 9 to 5 schedule in general
is crazy being in the office 9 to 5 like
if it was remote you get off at 5:00 and
you're home and everything's fine but
like I'm not home it takes me long to
get home and like like people that drive
to the office like it doesn't you don't
get off at 5: and I know it could be
worse I know I could be working longer
but like I literally get off it's pitch
black like I don't have energy how do
you have friends like how do you have
time to like meet like a guy I don't
know like how do you have time for like
dating like I don't have time for
anything and I'm like so stressed out
and I'm also getting my periods so
that's why I'm all emotional but like am
I so dramatic it's fine why are people
making fun of her I everything she said
was right